- When I have the
funniest thing to tell you
I was literally reading
my script last night
and I know you from things
and I, but I did not know
that your dad was Bono.
I had no idea.
I didn't know, I only know him as Bono.
Like I didn't know what his real name was
until I Googled last night.
(Kelly laughs)
- His real name is Paul.
It's a very unrockstar kind of name.
- [Kelly] It's very biblical. Yes.
I can't imagine like having
such a massive star for a parent
and then trying to get the business.
Like people probably don't
recognize that right off the bat.
Is that kind of cool?
- It's good. It's good.
I mean, yeah, nobody knows my last name.
So nobody knows who I am,
which is actually kind of fun.
- Yeah.
- I'm lucky I'm not like a Jagger
or McCartney or something like that.
- No, that's what I'm saying.
It's actually, I think I
get like why people would
be proud of it, but I think if it were me,
if I were you, I would
love that nobody knows
the last name of it.
You know what I'm saying?
And you get to have your own.
You've gotten your, you
made your mark on your own.
That's like the coolest thing ever.
Anyway, I'm always a fan of you.
And then I was like, "Oh, I had no idea."
So anyway, I called you
Eve, speaking of names,
but that's not even your
name. I Googled you.
You have like a thousand names.
Can you tell us your full name?
(chuckles)
- It's very embarrassing.
My parents were hippies.
I, there's nothing. I don't
know how to explain this.
- Yeah.
- But my real name is Memphis
Eve Sunny Day Iris Hewson.
- Okay, here's the thing
I'm going to tell you
this is how I found out who your dad was.
I literally was going through the thing
and I saw one of the
questions in the script
and I was like, "Wait, what's her name?"
And I was like, "Oh, her
parents were stoners."
I was like they've had to been stoners.
And then all of a sudden, the
next question was about Bono.
And I was like, "Oh my God, I nailed it!"
(laughs)
- You did.
No, I really am the poster
child for, you know,
those people magazines
like "Celebrity kids,
the craziest names" like that's me.
That's who I am.
- You know what, though.
You are all those names.
You claim all of those.
It's a beautiful name. All of them.